der junge mann die map ist einfach nur
megageil alter hier ist auch noch die
gross tritt martin groß ist das haus von
der junge mann räumt alle ein weiter der
bastard würde penetriert und es ist
einfach jeder junge mann ist die karte
geil
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer gta 5 bis 10 san andreas matt
vorstellung in minecraft zweifel games
zusammen mit max heier servus und wir
haben uns hier schon so geile karte
genommen lässt und kometen die haben wir
direkt bei in unserem haus in der martha
fucking probstried gepackt da wo wir
hier nämlich gerade sind jetzt übrigens
anders eine dumme kuh
wir haben es jetzt gedacht ich habe
diese map hier im internet gefunden und
sie wird als gta 5 oder sein andreas
matt dargestellt und die groupe speed
gibt es ja nicht nur uns andreas sondern
auch in gta 5 richtig max binder dem
extra noch mal nachgeschaut und es gibt
wirklich die größten gta 5 und auch in
minecraft ist einfach so in mark ronson
der san andreas experte ich zur zeit der
gta 5 experte weil ich das spiel gerade
bei 70 prozent habe glaube ich
und deswegen haben wir uns gedacht wir
das ganze hier zusammen vorstellen den
download findet ihr in der beschreibung
wir werden jetzt diese map ganz langsam
mal durchgehen wartet ich kann man ganz
gut mal ein pferd hier runter gehen kann
dass hier an ketten dass sie so hoch ist
riesig und wir werden dann gleich auf
jeden fall des wütenden langes video wir
werden die map komplett hier durchgehend
und deswegen oh ich hoffe dass jetzt
nicht all zu viel schaden wenn ich denen
erzähle ich lass ihn einfach langsam
runter lassen und werden soll
so jetzt nimm dich mutter fliegt durch
die eltern dass ihr weg darunter wie so
häufig weil man verkraften und es ist
möglich ist so episch ich habe die map
das erste mal gesehen habe gedacht das
kann nicht wahr sein weil gta san
andreas in minecraft es gibt ungefähr
nichts vettel weil es sind zwei
richtigkeit ich spiele einfach zu boden
fällt ihr müsst euch geben
ja die lust euch auf jeden fall
runterladen und schreit gibt doch bei
van bon ho wenn wir so einen zweifel
games event irgendwie organisieren
sollen mit dieser map hier ja auf jeden
fall hammergeil das geht mal daumen hoch
und weiß nicht was ich mache das bei 20
jahre sind nein
schafft die 5000 dann kann man so was
uns vor daran sei das ist das ist ein
ewiger aufwand müsse was organisieren
aber schon merken also suite wonach yaz
waits bruder wohnt hier in seiner wut
und ja hier drüben mal lieber luca ich
bin generell erst mal ein bisschen
umschauen wir wollen uns auf jeden fall
alles ganz genau anschauen und es ist
eigentlich echt genauso wie in gta san
andreas muss man sagen ist wirklich
sojapflanze mit dem klo der du schon
alles halt minecraft spiel und es ist
mir herrn sehr die hinten geht raus
dahin raten und guck guck dir das mal an
ihr pressed to play basketball ist so
üppig wie geil ist diese merkmal hier es
ist
ich stehe direkt vor die alte dame sogar
eingestellt das ist so episch weil er
den ball
ihr kennt kennt ihr das man kann hier
wirklich in gta auch in gta san andreas
auf basketball spielt und jetzt kann man
das hier in minecraft es ist einfach so
fucking malaria korb geworfen ich habe
ein korb geworfen habe ich kann hier
sind wir in irgendeiner wird in der
nicht erhöht denn regen stehen da kommen
wir noch mal rausgehen das nächste
gebäude und hier vorne
auf diesem grauen dach da wo jetzt die
kiste ist es auch geil gemacht bei
orchesters liegt normalerweise immer die
tech nein rum
zum beispiel maschinenpistole aus gta
san andreas und ist einfach so und wie
hast du dieses gibt doch immer ein
gebrauch gehabt max wie habe ich
überhaupt gehabt dass du deine
helikopters drauf gelandet ach so ja
natürlich
wir hätten wir auch mit unserem pferd
helikopter landen können jedenfalls um
an die kisten hier zu kommen muss man
halt also ich weiß nicht ob das hier die
kisten sind wieder die kisten da drin
ist er besser übrigens immer
unterschiedlich muss man halt erst
dieses ding zu machen und ist mittendrin
es ist auf jeden fall gemacht hier wohnt
ja richtig nach hier die große haus des
ganzen haus zieht jetzt mutter ist
gestorben und dann ist er zurückgekommen
von der west- oder austrickst keine
ahnung wir sind immer irgendwie wissen
abgeschlossen also man kommt da nicht so
durch das aber auch ein echtes spiel
sind aber in minecraft hat auch deswegen
hat es mit mega geil gemacht dass sein
tod von nachmachen
das ist wirklich richtig richtet sich
somit die heizung web einfach finde ich
ja ich hab dir gesehen wirklich war
verliebt hier vorne kommen wir zum haus
von ryder der dann später seagate verrät
der blöde hundezone ist wird bei dem
auch ganz gezielt ihr penner alltag
alles kaputt machen hier ja die kleine
[ __ ] khlong prapa kanal neiße galt er
als puren so ein alter wieder fallen
außerdem einfach genauso die täter auch
walter reparierte wieder wenn du trägst
und hier sind wir unter der brücke wo in
der allerletzten mission durch dieses
ding hier oben der feuerwehr typ da der
polizist unterstützt und verrückt und es
so wunderschön ich liebe geht erst
andreas wenn jetzt auch liebt dann lasst
einfach ein leichter was eure lieblings
mission 19 andreas genauer und ja hier
vorne immer weiter immer weiter hier
kann ja echt in alle häuser eingesetzt
diese strecken negative dias wurden na
ja da sind die ganzen abgepackten typen
die da im raum stehen auf der street und
hier wohnte james erste freundin
er hat ja während dem spiel um die 20
stück oder gehasst und das ist glaube
ich die denise wenn ich mich vielleicht
erinnern und es ist einfach sogar wenn
man kann überall rein und wenn man hier
mal so ein bisschen lang fliegt ich weiß
nicht wie groß ist die mir bist du schon
mal zum rand gefüllt ist das das ende da
mit dem glas abgesteckt aber es ist
riesig
wenn man das alles kennt die räder
genommen deshalb eine map wie man
überhaupt nicht kennen muss und man kann
sie trotzdem zocken ist einfach richtig
richtig und vor allem wenn man sich
treffen wir ja wo bist du ja ich bin
doch in dem gebäude
denkst du bist die map ist auch wirklich
geil gebaut also kann mir nicht anders
sagen das ist einfach
insgesamt so müssen die bürger laut wo
bist du ich bin hier als staub der
burger mainz bürgerschaft bürgerschaft
steht hier wahrscheinlich immer jetzt
das kino maxx kino war im echten
spielekiste ich weiß es gar nicht ich
denke dass da wo die kisten sind im
echten spiel irgendwelche waffen
versteckt sind ja oder als sonst so ein
jetpack fallschirm oder so was halt ja
genau solche sachen aber schon mal guckt
man hier die ampel an
er hat mir noch nie heftig ist das guckt
ihr amt wie geil das ist einmal mit so
viel liebe zum detail gemacht und es ist
so alter das ist im detail und ihre
autos diese kleinen autos auch immer das
ist vor allem reifen mit solchen bilder
spielt dann so drin sein als gegen das
sogar möglich dass wirklich mit abstand
einen der geist maps und diese auch
wirklich groß also weiß von wem ist ihm
etwas
ihr habt den link in der beschreibung
den könnte auf jeden fall einen
diamanten da lasse ich glaube dann in
minecraft forum war das vorher genau
diese weise nicht und hier ist dieser
fette ding ohne gott alter sogar da
unten der tunnel ist da wohl bei dieser
einen epischen verfolgungsjagd durch
vier reinfeldt aber dass noch was bitte
hat ist zerstört man erst in wedding wo
war durchgehend machen
ja auf jeden fall ja was dann ja okay
okay das war nix passieren wirklich also
wirklich gibt daumen hoch damit wir so
ein episches battle hier sehen wollt das
wäre echt hammer geil vor allem
eventuelle
dann können wir was führt es für mich
natürlich
dann würden auch die metal machen ob wir
mit macht einfach alles das ticken hier
hat das mit mir richtig richtig weil
dann machen wir so ein drive by in der
großstadt einfach ist eine sprache und
es wirklich echt die map ist es wirklich
wenn ihr geht erst andreas kennt das ist
einfach eins zu eins platz und ladet
euch einfach runter wenn wir kommen hier
nichts von dem typen der die ich hab
dich halt nur gefunden und das ist
hammer geil
es ist mir egal und hier steht so lange
hier steht ein panzer ja diese ganzen
kleinen sachen die hier so gezeigt
werden und so was alles das kennt ihr
doch bestimmt aber hier los santos
allerdings wenn man wenn man früher in
san andreas mit dem panzer herum
gefahren ist und am aufgemacht hat das
kennt doch jeder
und hier ist hier ist die arena
wo die ganzen autos rum stehen uns ja
genau wo man dann die autos alle
freischalten kann und so was wollen wir
rein
man kann sogar eingehen wir haben sogar
junge die haben die arena nachgebaut ja
nicht irgendwie zugemacht bist du da
rein fliegen ja ich bin ich bin schon in
der arena drin also so heftig da wo wir
die ganzen rennen machen musste es ist
so heftig nein da die ganzen rennen wo
ich immer charakter im spiel haben wir
1000 anläufe für gebracht das ist echt
heftig geil
also wenn ihr keine ab wenn diese ganzen
cent bildchen uns so was alles boa ein
neuer teil z 0
wenn ihr wenn ihr in die trave server
oder so habt dann ladet euch die map
runter und live ein paar freunde ein
oder sowas und dann dann zockt ihr die
einfach zusammen weil sie so heftiger
und hier oben ist ja cool hier oben ist
auch wieder eine kiste weil da liegt
auch eine waffe und sogar nur doppel
kiste aber das ist allein allein diese
ganzen dieses ganze detailreiche alte
alles um spiel einfach mal minecraft
nachgebaut
alles ist an sich so gewünscht hat ich
wollte zum beispiel immer mal meine
eigene heimatstadt in minecraft nachbarn
und die bremer geht der finanzdaten
solltest dir dieses kanalisationssystem
so baut lukas lukas heimatschützer nein
also das wollten wir machen und dann
machen setzen dass die leute einfach
aber damit ist wirklich über gta ist
einfach die geilste spiel reisen finden
mit assassin's creed oftmals anderen
fifa es ist einfach ist einfach geil war
schon immer der den kampfnamen kommen
wir lassen dich auch immer helikoptern
den kopf dann und wir müssen ein
bisschen weiter gucken oder gar nicht
fertig ja okay was ist das hier also wie
gesagt so viel gezeigt nur wenn schon
freien modus internet so viel von der
story kennen hier kann man zocken
in fabriken nehme ich an
weil hier auf den kritiker laufen also
wie man kann ja im echten sondern
andreas nicht in jedes gebäude reingehen
und wenn ihr einfach walter das ist eine
presse.zeit.de wenn ihr einfach wenn ihr
die gebäude erkunden wollte niemanden
gta san andreas nicht betreten können
dann ladet euch einfach runter und guckt
euch an was da so drin ist das ist
einfach nein
luca factor geht einfach
der orient und parkour alter die kritik
am obersten rand so heftig wo bin ich
hier gelandet kann man da wieder raus
ich habe mir im weg programm kommen
irgendeine halle leute treffern ein
was siehst du denn jetzt alters die
einfach an
hier ist knackig wenn das fahrzeug des
ksc aus san andreas rohde lisa laden ist
daher geflogen bin hab ich dir gesagt
hat was neben mir baby klack klack in
youtube ist einfach geil
ich bin fasziniert gerade was machst du
denn fristen ich habe mir etwas
mitgebracht
warum kann ich mir einen burger hast du
die ganzen items die hier gab bei mir
sieht diesen teil einer mordanklage dem
bürger geben bürger geben in börger
schnell moment komme langsam zu warten
zu lassen
so du kriegst du erst mal ein brot und
da kriegst du dein fleisch und dann
musst du nur ein schritt dahin war ich
nicht aber das ist wirklich alleine
schon eine ich glaube es gibt das sogar
im ort wo man autos in minecraft oder ja
und es gibt auch ein klares motto mit
waffen wird die beiden motzen der map
hier
das ist einfach richtig machen sie wenn
nein also auch mit mods installieren
also event geht das glaube ich da nicht
mitmacht weil dann jeder die man braucht
uns aber wir beide einfach runterladen
jetzt darum fahren so jamann
wenn ihr das sehen wollte es ist eine
epische sachen dessen ordentliche
aufwand alle hashtag kruse gangsters
lenkt
der schreibt das okay was haben wir hier
im itt r8 allerdings ja junge es ist so
heftig dass stößt diese diese videothek
wo sind die ganzen waffen laden ja
stimmen wie nation die richtig an den
echten ja glaub ich weiß nicht ob hier
im radius von der von der kuppel einer
sb pflegen was zurück zu groß ich weiß
das mrt irgendwo ist ach so ja ich bin
installiert damit liegt aber
normalerweise nur eine eine pistole und
spektive hier vorne müsste doch
eigentlich das krankenhaus sein oder
beim ganz behindert im kopf glaube
wurden nicht in die falsche richtung
beziehungsweise bist du müsste das auch
noch im radius liegen und das ist es
einfach heftig dass die wetter her
einfach so dass ich gar nicht
man kann ihn alles reingehen weil es
einfach so episch ist ja was ist das
hier das kloster ist dass mehrere so
eine shopping mall
da kann man ja auch nicht jedes geschäft
rein gewässern andreas und hier kann man
einfach alles eingehen also das ist
schon geil was hat ja bald die zeit
kaputt machen kannst hier habe ich meine
dass auch alles nicht meinen besten
andreas ist bestimmt so dass die sachen
wo wir nicht rein kann das ihnen einfach
nichts ist aber hier kannst du in die
sachen reingehen war und dann kriegst du
kostet das den strauß schwackenberg
hier sehen wir dann klappen berg was
wird zu fressen
die haben immer feuer drin bei klassen
werden hier hinten liegt mir mein freund
max war alles viel besser als in meinen
als sie mal bei kumpels waren wir haben
so gespielt haben wir hier einen
verschachtelten ganz viele waffen haben
gewartet bis die bullen kommen
ja man jede drin alle leute getötet hat
man irgendwie sechs sterne und die
bringen einfach nichts machen
ja man ist da drin die bullen kommen
rein und immer klappt dann habe ich
immer so gemacht und hab dann hier das
derzeit für für unendlich leben schreibt
mir die gp konnte alles in die kita
geben
ein neuer leben einfach so erleben alles
scheint einfach alles einfach alles
einfach alles
wir machen jetzt ein bisschen rummst
klicks kaufen okay okay
wollen wir wollen wir näher kommen
menschen in verliere ich weiß nicht ob
pflanze schon frei 26.2 gibt ich weiß
nicht immer dass der server installiert
ich weiß nicht wie der automat
funktioniert aber heiner brand macht das
mit herten
das können wir das kann man machen wir
probieren probieren es auf jeden fall zu
machen aber ihr müsst natürlich dafür
und was zeigen dass extremismus da ein
lesenswertes machen das kostet und so
viel zeit und dann müsst ihr schon
bisher schon alles geben dafür dass wir
das machen aber es lohnt sich auf jeden
fall wird es wird megageil na gut dann
würde ich sagen aber gut zurück in die
großstadt auf jeden fall vision data
stellt dieser kanals immer gut
vorstellen dass erfurt bei mir viel hier
ist der highway ja wo man bestimmt schon
durch 1000 polizeisperren durchgefahren
ist wenn man ein echter geht ära player
ist klar
global sei ja ja was könnte man noch
machen zum abschluss die map in die luft
nachdem die map lassen wir so wie sie es
mag die magix ag außerhalb dieses
[ __ ] haus davon den player heustreu
ja-stimmen und ihr der basta lassen die
luft jagen
natürlich ist doch logisch mit dem
mausrad kleiner bastard hast du zieht
der verraten gebunden sind erhöht zu
bluten computer stimmt natürlich nicht
aber ich hab' ich habe es also gesucht
ich habe mir ich habe mir alle watts ist
ehrlich konnte später konnte ich
kamehameha machen geht der mund fliegen
und alles ist also gar also luca
genießen wir das spektakel so kleiner
parasit wir noch einmal
das ist genauso wie in gta 5 wo man
etwas in diesem container wo der typ
wohnt in diesen anhänger einfach in den
fluss mara in chips dass ihr 1000
das ist jetzt eine strafe also ich bin
verliebt in die karte ich glaube einige
von euch werden mich verstehen können
bin ich wenn ihr geht hier also it und
tanja wir sagen ihr wisst was ihr zu tun
habt wenn wir so etwas machen sollen und
dann erst bei uns bestehende tief gut
bei uns dann würde ich sagen haut frei
bleiben